there's a new sheriff
in
town sportier and more aggressive than
the last one
muscular and armed with six cylinders
it wears its badge with pride
but what is this new car patrolling the
streets
from bmw says the new 2 series is a
logical development the coupe is more
able and bigger than its predecessor and
has more powerful engines
it's got a lot more to offer and better
driving dynamics and that makes it fit
perfectly between the one and three
series
does the 2 series really drive so much
differently from bmw's 1 series we'll
soon find out
the coupe feels like a race car for the
road thanks to its engine and sporty
chassis
but the manufacturer says fuel
consumption is moderate 7.6 liters of
super for 100 kilometers
not bad for an engine that puts out 240
kilowatts
those horses under the hood hope the
coupe spread from zero to one hundred
kilometers an hour in just four point
eight seconds
says the 2 series seems quite
respectable out on the highway
especially with its juggernaut engine
now it's time to take the car to the
limits on a race track for that matas
will turn it over to a professional test
driver
so it's off to the races
las vegas speedway
race car tester floyd dietrich will see
what the 2 series can do
the engine's 450 newton meters of torque
ensure that the car accelerates
powerfully out of the curves
the eight-speed automatic transmission
gear changes are instant
florian notes that despite its increased
dimensions the two series has become
more manageable and agile its driving
dynamics are stronger but it's still
easy to drive even at the limits of its
capabilities
the chassis has changed a lot the axles
are the same basic design as the one
series but have been completely reworked
the same goes for the suspension
components and the steering
kinematics
is
the interior is understated and
functional
the steering wheel provides a good grip
and the instruments are easy to read
the seats are sporty and have good side
support
on the dashboard the gps monitor is
positioned above the radio and air vents
a special feature is the driving
experience control switch with its eco
mode and two sporty steering modes
not only the stiffness of the suspension
is adjustable but also the response of
the engine the characteristics of the
automatic gearbox and the feel of the
steering
the coupe uses the brakes to control
slides would-be race drivers can request
the optional limited slip differential
which improves acceleration out of
curves
with that the perfectly balanced 2
series can be wielded as precisely as a
surgical scalpel
experienced drivers can be sure they
won't lose control even when drifting
through a curve
so this is a two series that's in the
running for first place
our car tester sums up the 2 series is
clearly different from the 1 series most
obviously in its looks the interior may
be a bit less roomy because of the
sloping trunk but if you want a coupe
that is more compact than a 4 or 1
series bmw or also a mercedes clk then
matas thinks the 2 series is a good
alternative
an alternative that has no reason to run
from the competition if you want to buy
an m class 235i in germany be prepared
to pay 43 750 euros if you want the 8
gear sport automatic transmission you'll
need another 2 240 euros
say hello to the first hot hatch from
kia
with its new cgt the korean car maker
wants to take on the pocket rockets from
volkswagen and opal
our car tester carla simons wants to see
whether it's got what it takes
let's start on the outside
the seed treads in line between boy
racer aggression and range topping style
with its aggressive but sweeping lines
the little hot hatch certainly looks the
part with its angry face but flashes of
chrome give it a more upmarket feel the
design is the work of former volkswagen
designer peter schreier
the kia looks just as good from behind
as it does from the front
the twin rear light clusters dominate
the rear and the twin exhaust hint
there's something special under the hood
and there is a 1.6 liter turbocharged
petrol engine
time now to hit the road
kaola will be putting the kia through
its paces on an old race circuit there's
no better place to unleash all of the
gt's 150 kilowatts of power
she says the seeds is a real hoot to
drive there's a lot of power to tap but
she feels the car doesn't really hook up
well coming out of the turns it's like
there's a delay in getting the power to
the front wheels
but the cgt makes up for that with its
sweet handling that makes it a real
blast to drive in the twisties
the sporting flare on the outside
continues on the inside
red stitching and lettering remind you
that this is no run-of-the-mill car
there's no shortage of buttons and shiny
inlays in here
the wrap around seats are crafted from
suede and make you feel like you're in a
race car
the kia doesn't skimp on spec and is
fitted with a handy rear view camera to
aid parking
despite being in the compact class the
seeds trunk offers a truly cavernous 380
liters of storage space it also has a
false floor in which to store valuables
as it is carol is a big fan of the
inlays on the steering wheel she thinks
they look the real deal the only problem
she says is that they can be a bit of a
headache at night
they reflect the light from all of the
buttons and gizmos here in the cabin
and that can be a bit of a distraction
the last thing you want is to be
distracted because this hot hatch really
packs a punch it accelerates from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in just 7.7
seconds
despite that performance it's not going
to break the bank kia says the car can
cover 100 kilometers with a relatively
low 7.4 liters of gas
our test car was a bit more thirsty and
consumed 10 liters but that's still in
line with the competition
time for the final word on the kia
kaola thinks it's a genuine alternative
to the other hot hatches out there but
she would like to see a bit more
attention to detail in the interior all
in all though she says the kia has got
it right with a new cgt
another thing that appeals to her is the
price
the top spec gt track version that we
tested is available in germany for
around 27 000 euros
mercedes has lifted the covers on the
replacement for the viano people carrier
the new v-class shares many styling cues
with its predecessor but the biggest
changes can be found on the inside
it's leather seats and sweeping dash
wouldn't look out of place in a mercedes
c-class the new model will hit showrooms
in may and is expected to retail for
around 41 000 euros in germany
volkswagen is raising the stakes in the
hot hatch segment with its revised golf
r with 221 kilowatts and 380 newton
meters of torque going through a
four-wheel drive system the new r
promises to be a blast come winter
its dsg 6-speed dual clutch automatic
transmission helps it to get from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in just 4.9
seconds
it'd be yours for around 38 000 euros in
germany
old vw buses like the t2 have legions of
fans the last one rolled off the
production lines in germany in 1979
but in sao paulo brazil production of
the t2 continued right up until the end
of last year
it was a huge success during its
lifetime for a whopping 56 years an
average of 20 000 rolled off the
assembly line every year
now it's the end of an era the van got
all dressed up for its swan song with a
limited edition model
volkswagen sales director jochen funk
says the old gal is a very specific
product some brazilians regard the vw as
a brazilian brand of german descent
they
at first vw's had to be imported to
brazil but in 1957 a plant in oshieta
began building the t2's predecessor the
t1
demand grew rapidly from just 370 sold
in the first year to over 41 000 four
years later production of the t2 began
in 1975
signaling the start of a success story
that lasted for almost four decades
without changing the van's basic
character vw constantly optimized the
vehicle
the limited last edition model was
originally envisioned as a batch of just
600 but demand was so great that vw
doubled that to 1200.
maurizio augusto marx is the proud owner
of one of the first vw vans ever built
and spent a year and a half restoring
the vehicle with original parts
he replaced the headlights and the
engine he says there are only four 1950
panel vans in brazil
and only 36 of them in the whole world
in brazil the van is a volkswagen in the
literal sense it's a real people's car
the multi-purpose vehicle can still be
seen on almost every street corner there
are no limits to the inventive spirit
with which people modify it the t2 is
often seen with the most wacky
modifications it can be a police car a
fire truck a mobile snack bar a tv
broadcasting studio or an ambulance
the vw van is good for just about
everything
everyone loved this jack of all trades
but it wasn't able to keep up with the
times stricter safety and emission
regulations helped kill off the cult
classic
jochen funk explains that the van was
designed more than 60 years ago when
airbags and advanced braking systems
didn't exist
even the best engineers can't fit these
upgrades into a vw bus
so now regulations mean that the company
had to end production despite continuing
high demand
the final last edition model number 1200
was never put up for sale it was
carefully packed up and sent by
freighter home to wolfsburg germany
a special place was waiting for it at
the volkswagen auto museum here the t2
enjoys its retirement among its
relatives
head of the museum's vintage car team is
sad that this perennial icon is no
longer being manufactured he's glad that
the last of the species is in his own
hands but says that is meager
consolation
is
the t2 is going nowhere soon with such a
loyal following plenty of existing ones
won't be jumped or retired for a long
time to come
chevrolet's corvette stingray still has
a dedicated cult following in the early
1960s chevy one of america's big four
set out to give established sports car
makers like jaguar and maserati a run
for their money
the new corvette's design reflected the
typical sports car styling of the time a
long engine compartment with a snappy
fastback
the shape character and image of this
automotive legend were american through
and through until the arrival of the
dodge viper in 1992 the corvette was the
only true sports car made entirely in
the usa
under the hood of course the stingray
had a v8 packing 250 horsepower in the
basic version
an optional extra was a four speed stick
shift which was a usual option for an
american car
the stingray was also the first corvette
to offer two different body styles a
coupet and a convertible
chevrolet fitted successive models of
the stingray with bigger and bigger
engines
the v8 big block version sported a
business-like but fake air scoop on the
hood
throughout its five-year run the
stingray's basic form remained almost
unchanged that was also unusual in 1960s
america where new models appeared every
year
time now for a trip back in time the
corvette appeared a decade before the
stingray hit showrooms chevrolet
unveiled the first model
now known as the c1 to an admiring
public at the general motors motorama in
1953.
chevrolet engineer and race car driver
zora arcos duntov is known as the father
of the corvette he mounted a lean
two-seater fiberglass body on a robust
box frame a concept that has survived to
the current generation of corvettes
the corvette didn't get its famous v8
edge until 1956.
after that marriage the street cruiser
was transformed into a serious sports
car
in 1960 a corvette team entered the le
mans 24-hour race against the european
competition
taking eighth place overall but first in
its class
it was a good showing for the new kid on
the block
by the early 60s the original corvette
was beginning to look past its sell by
date the design department kicked around
various ideas until head designer bill
mitchell got inspiration for the first
corvette coupe
from an actual stingray the new stingray
was even sportier leaner and meaner
47 year old engineer oliver tripp is a
corvette fan body and soul he collects
everything connected with this
automotive icon
his impressive collection includes
corvettes from 1964 to 1996.
but his favorite is the c2 the stingray
model built from 1963-67
whenever he finds some time in his busy
schedule he takes one of his treasures
out for a spin
he says he dreamt of corvettes even as a
child he saw one as a small boy and
immediately fell in love with it
eventually he began collecting them
whenever he could he admits it's a
typical male dream
he explains that an american car
collector circles the c2 is the usa's
answer to the portion it handles very
well in comparison to its contemporaries
and relative to other vintage classic
sports cars it's still affordable
oliver trev had his blue 65 coupe
completely restored and customized to
his own specifications in the united
states
but corvette fan though he is he says
the performance of the big block v8 is
only just enough
american car fans call a corvette like
oliver's a sleeper that means it has
lots of power under the hood but
everything else is like the original
nowadays a stingray in good condition
can run a good 50 000 euros the most
sought after models are the big blocks
and split window coupes the best place
to find one if at all is in the united
states
you